how does a woman with five kids manage
to find a man a husband to get married
the best view in the world
[Music]
guys I'm in front of the cabin what I'm
about to say is not made up praying once
Allah right here is the equivalent to a
hundred thousand just a hundred pounds
can teach up to ten people how to pray
Salah we aren't saying we bring people
to umrah but we teach brothers and
sisters like Khalid how to pray Salah
the donor gets the reward so do not miss
on this reward click the button or the
link and donate
foreign
guys so the question some brothers who
are inclined to the red pill or who are
directly involved with a red pill are
amazed and shocked how does a woman with
five kids manage to find a man a husband
to get married
this is the question that's been asked
now where is this stemming from the
question that we wanted to ask is where
is the Curiosity the the annoyance yes
that they are indulged in or suffering
from why are they so surprised that a a
woman with five kids ended up getting
married this was the discussion at one
point with some people talking about
this which you guys know I don't need to
mention the names now I want to mention
some things
is it impossible for a woman with five
kids to get married now Allah says in
the Quran for him Allah all things are
possible that's number one we need to
understand our religion and our Deen we
do not follow feminism we do not follow
red pill we don't feel any of those pill
the only thing that we follow with the
Quran and the Sunnah so why is it why
does it come at a surprise for some
brothers why is it a hard pill
why is it so surprising that a woman
with five kids got married now let's put
some things in checks of course usually
sadly in the states that will like in
the times we live in for a woman to get
married when she's divorced let alone
with kids it is hard it's a reality so
I'm not here encouraging and sisters to
go get a divorce because I know there is
a phenomenon happening now where sisters
think the glass is green on the other
side no it's not we have many sisters
who come on bitter trip show and other
sisters where I know myself who are
finding it very very hard to get married
now this is a reality that it's it is
hard for sisters who end their marriages
on trivial matters and think it's all
grass or green on the other side they
end up seeing very very the dark side
where a lot of men sadly are after the
wrong things especially when you're with
kids especially with the South Asian
Community you are looked and frowned
upon now this is a reality however first
and thing first for sister inaya may
Allah preserve your marriage may Allah
protect you from evil eye may Allah
protect you and your husband and your
kids from evil eye and Hazard and and
um whatever it may be from those who
have Envy whoever it may be and I'm not
saying the people that I'm talking about
I'm talking generally may Allah preserve
your marriage because we do not want the
breakdown of the marriage unit I myself
I am so so happy my dear sister inaya
and whoever you are that you have found
your happiness you have found a man and
may Allah preserve you both and we want
the marriage unit to be intact that's
what we want follow the Quran that's why
I started the bitter truth Show the
marriage documentary is partly about
that as well and I'm working on another
project that's all pertaining to to
avoid the breakdown of the marriage of
unit now I want to speak to the Red Bull
Brothers putting that to a side
says
in the Quran that when you go your
separate ways you decide to go separate
ways then when they have almost reached
the end of their waiting period Then
retain them honorably or separate from
them on Ruby number one Allah is telling
you how to deal with a woman that you
want to divorce or you guys want to go
in separate ways honorably and call two
of you reliable men Witnesses either way
and let the witnesses bear true
testimony for the sake of Allah this is
enjoined on Whoever whomsoever has faith
in Allah in the last day and listen
carefully and whoever is mindful of
Allah he will make a way out for them
next verse and provide for them from
sources they could never imagine and
whoever puts their trust in Allah then
he alone is sufficient for them
certainly Allah achieves you as he Wills
Allah is already set a Destiny for
everything
will give a way out
why am I mentioning this because most of
these problems in this specific instance
are thinking with their logic now how
did Iblis fell into disbelief this is a
story we all need to understand why
Iblis was told to bow down to Adam
he said using my logic means logic
knuckle means what Allah is revealed yes
okay what he directly says
yes this comes from Allah and direct yes
so
logically it doesn't follow that I
should bow down to that being when I
believe logically I am better than him
listen carefully now you're thinking
about ali you went from marriage divorce
five kids sister with five kids and
married to a red pill to this there is a
direct connection correlation causation
how
he believes fell into disbelief because
he said logically this doesn't follow
therefore I'm gonna ascribe a mistake to
Allah because this is how we fell into
this belief not because he committed not
because he didn't bow down no because
Adam was told not take it from the tree
he ate from the tree did he fell into
disbelief no but because he Italy said
therefore I believe Allah you are
telling me to do something which is
wrong
rejecting one of Allah's attributes the
all-knowing you are saying Allah you
don't know I know
now the same thing is happening with the
red pill and I'm not saying they are
likely please I'm not saying that
they are looking and thinking logically
a woman with five kids should not be
able to get married
it should not be able to we say from the
Quran Allah says for Allah all things
are possible and we read from Surah
Allah will give a way out from places
you can never imagine
my dear brothers who are obsessed with a
red pill or inclined to them we do not
follow your don't you respect nonsense
this is nonsense we call out feminism we
call out the sisters who promote
feminism But Me Myself whoever knows
what I've done for the past 10 years
yeah knows that I call out both male
YouTubers sister female YouTubers and if
I'm wrong justly yes if I'm wrong and
I've done a mistake Haram but it may be
I am open to be called out not I think
you've done something wrong it seems
like to my man had just something wrong
no so the point I'm seeing in I'm not
sure is this in Islam it is possible for
a woman to have 10 kids 20 kids 50 kids
to get married to a man who loves her
this is our Deen anyone that thinks
otherwise and thinks no it's not
possible I'm so sorry you are following
other man-made Woman made laws
that's the reason why I wanted to do
this video to educate our brothers to
get rid of this disturbing toxic
mentality of the red pill now is
everything the red fool says false no
there are a lot of facts they took
however they mix it with sugar hat
that's why we have the Quran Sunnah
because there's nothing mixed with
Shabba had or something that is dirty no
it is pure it is pure so therefore what
I'm saying to my brothers and sisters
who are listening to this be it feminism
be a red pill for Allah subhanahu ta'ala
all things are possible and a woman who
has five kids like I said before can get
married so therefore number one that's
the thing and I'm gonna finish on this
note inshallah number two to even have
that at a discussion point and talking
about it can fall into back by thing and
talking about the sister and her family
can even fall into slander if what
you're saying is not true if what you're
if if you're talking about them it is
backbiting if what you say is not true
it says slander and the prophet
sallallahu said I guarantee Paradise for
the one who can secure guarantee me
what's between their lips and what's
between their private parts
let's be careful Roman sisters it is
Ramadan we should and outside of Ramadan
as well
let's be careful and let's be very very
very careful because believe me salaf
used to say we would rather stand in
front of our Lord with 70 sins meaning
said 70 used to be the word of
expression of many between us and our
Lord then one sin between me and me
wrong in someone
may Allah protect us subhanallah that's
all I'm going to say may
Allah's marriage may Allah keep affirm
and I ask Allah to bless their marriage
to the day they die and inshallah in
Jannah
and that's it that's all I want to say
inshallah this does not mean by the way
I'm promoting sister and I owe anyone
for that matter okay because their
social public figures themselves there's
things I agree and disagree with them
just to make a disclaimer I'm not
promoting I'm just saying that this
disease that we have of this attitude
this is from no other than shaytan we
take the nakan what Allah said reveal
from his messenger over our uncle over
what this little limited brain yes this
little brain yeah okay it's quite a
little at it yeah all of us we take that
over this all day every day if not we
will fall into disbelief may Allah
protect us